are you aware of the risks lurking
within your technology landscape join us
today as we uncover the truth behind
Shadow I.T and how it can impact your
security compliance and operational
efficiencies
in today's session we will explore some
real world examples that illustrates
what shadow I.T entails its underlying
causes potential benefits and inherent
risks
let's start off with have you heard of
Shadow I.T
and how it's a big problem for
Enterprise businesses
it refers to Software
Hardware
or it resources that are in the
Enterprise Network
without your it teams knowledge
and it's very important for us to
differentiate Shadow I.T with malicious
assets because Shadow I.T is not malware
per se
it is unsanctioned resources deployed by
your authorized users
here's a few examples to really paint
the picture
let's say your employees are sharing
files from their own personal Dropbox or
thumb drive instead of using the company
approved file sharing system
or they're possibly joining meetings in
Zoom instead of the company standard
which may be WebEx
or even using innocuous grammar checks
or maybe using their own personal mobile
and laptop devices in the Enterprise
Network
unfortunately for businesses and their
security teams around 80 percent of
employees are preferring to use Shadow
I.T because of its quick adaptability
and adoption across the team as well as
its perceived Superior functionality
some of the employees may even be
recommended to use these different
platforms and applications from their
clients and partners maybe to enhance
collaboration on projects per se
the trend here that highlights for us is
that there is a high demand in
efficiency and flexibility in today's
Workstation
the flip side here is that as I
mentioned before Shadow it is operating
outside the awareness and protection of
the IT team
so any vulnerabilities that could have
been tied to them have gone unaddressed
making Shadow I.T Prime targets for
adversaries
and according to the article published
in 2023 by IBM the average cost of a
data breach in a U.S company is around
9.4 million dollars the reason why I'm
bringing this up is because Shadow I.T
is actually a key component that
increases the likelihood of a data
breach
now let's dive into some key points on
Shadow I.T such as the risks and
challenges that it brings forth here's
what you need to know
there is increase in exposure
on average organizations that undergo an
attack surface management review
discover that they have 30 percent more
exposed assets than they were initially
aware of and as mentioned since there's
so many new assets that are coming into
their Vision there was a lot of
vulnerabilities that could have gone
under their radar as well making it a
key risk to the business
another risk is data insecurity
with storing and accessing data across
multiple Shadow I.T applications and
devices it poses the concern of data in
consistency because you're having this
data scattered across multiple different
resources and they could be accessed and
distributed as an official invalid and
outdated data
another risk is compliance
with regulations out there such as HIPAA
PCI DSS and gdpr they have very strict
regulations on handling personally
identifiable information and if you're
not compliant you could risk paying a
hefty fee you could risk your own
reputation being on the line and even
facing legal action against your
business
and last but definitely not least
because there's a whole lot of risks out
there with Shadow I.T but the fourth one
that we're going to be exploring today
is business efficiencies
thank you
not all of Shadow I.T or multiple
different applications and resources
that are Shadow I.T is going to
seamlessly integrate into your it
infrastructure and this could really
hinder workflows and the sharing of
information because if your it
Department steps in and tries to change
anything on the network or any
connecting resources it could really
impede or completely disrupt a relied
upon Shadow I.T process from executing
that the team really relies on to
continue their workflow
with all of these risks in mind I also
want to pull out a stat here from a an
article published in 2022 which covers
the surface the state of attack surface
management
and
it shows that eight
in 10
that's right 8 and 10 organizations have
fallen victim to Shadow I.T compromise
within the last year and even though the
risks are very apparent and they've only
been increasing so has the usage of
Shadow I.T because employees now have
very simple and easy access to SAS based
platforms they're also using their
personal mobile and laptop devices on
the Enterprise Network with the shift to
the remote Workforce so that's also a
very scary but transparent view for us
to have on the risks that shadow I.T can
bring forth
now with a clear understanding of the
risks of Shadow I.T it's also important
for us to consider the benefits that may
come to the team and the company for us
to address it accordingly so let's cover
some of the benefits
starting off
with an increase in agility
so Shadow I.T enables your employees to
adapt quickly and adopt two different
platforms that they choose so they're
also leveraging new technologies that
are going to increase the agility of the
business
there's also the benefit of an increased
flexibility
with your employees because now that
they're leveraging what they deem are
the tools that best fit their role
they're performing in a more productive
way and they're also having a more
exciting experience that they're more
satisfied with
another benefit here is streamlining
your it assets because with Shadow I.T
it's reducing the cost and resources you
need to onboard new it assets onto your
company
so taking the risks and benefits into
account it's time for us to effectively
mitigate Shadow I.T
now let's talk about mitigations
so we've seen that even though there are
a lot of risks tied to Shadow I.T we
can't ignore the benefits that the team
gives back for us as feedback we don't
want to completely eliminate Shadow I.T
because we see that a lot of them maybe
work more productively and they're more
satisfied with their workflow so to
address that we can then bring Shadow
I.T
that we currently have identified along
the way
and align it
with our current standard
it
security
protocols
so while still taking the team's
feedback into the benefits while still
keeping a priority on security
another mitigation is implementing
different tools that are out there to
really help us addressing Shadow I.T
such as ASM or attack service Management
Solutions that will continuously monitor
our internet facing assets or anything
that has been exposed along the way to
also discover and identify the
vulnerabilities there so you can assess
them and mitigate them accordingly
another tool is going to be Cloud asset
security brokers
this tools allows you to establish
secure connections between your
employees and your Cloud assets while
also implementing security measures such
as encryption access controls and
malware detections along the way and it
also has some abilities to continuously
fetching your Cloud assets so anything
that had been previously unknown will
come to light
by understanding the risks and benefits
that comes with Shadow I.T and
implementing the appropriate security
measures organizations can harness the
advantages while mitigating the
vulnerabilities ensuring security and
efficiency in their technology landscape
thank you if you like this video and
want to see more like it please like And
subscribe if you have questions please
drop them in the comments below